this is captain PewDiePie coming on on
the Swedish Thunder we're a little rocky
but we can do this god dammit we have to
defend the fjords you're dead you're so
dead oh you're dead your mama then hey
hey don't shoot back at me that's
illegal
no oh god um that's fine now we're just
gonna land now we're just gonna line
floor again
mission failed all right that does not
count that does not count I literally
just got started
come on this is so sad Sweden lost in
war impossible okay no let me just show
you the power of floor gang from the
skies we're playing war thunder by the
way I really like this game
even though it's a bastard see if we can
get some good games come on oh yeah yeah
I know this this is the Battle of Sweden
vs. Spain yeah
those yeah I'm sorry Spain your ceiling
gang what can I say confirm come on I
think if this seems a little unmatched
this doesn't feel like it's fair oh he
doesn't see me oh oh oh don't try and
escape oh hey oh it's coming back damn a
stolen we must defend the homeland from
their turf oh oh oh critical
there's no escape only that dirty of it
you can run but you can't hide
yeah oh no oh you thought you could
escape look at this fool I will get him
I will get him oh yeah if you download
the game you get this skin by the way if
you send link in the description guys
it's pretty cool I never seen anyone
else with it
I wonder why cuz you dad your mama dad
this is my kill you better not next one
oh where are you going what are you
going to dead dead town but do not drive
it to me crazy Spaniards this is intense
I love this better with snow escape only
that come on come on come on come on oh
you want some oh look at this fool Oh
someone else shoot me I don't think so
I don't think so don't driving to me
take always do that hey idiot stop to
stare your this I take the skin too
seriously I'm sorry
come on the three crimes I must defend
them why is he so high come down freakin
ceiling gang get down from there
he's escaping to the ceilings yeah I
gotta do my my Swedish battle cry this
is what the villager the Vikings needs
to do
just intimidate their victims before
pillaging their villages they would have
tambourines on the airplanes in Sweden
[Music]
I'm so ready they're all gonna die
can we do a kill still yeah boyee
crashed idiot oh no my friend is in
danger this will not happen on my watch
[Music]
oh nice
you can't escape I got a little too
excited playing this game yeah getting
sweet mum I got a critical hit two
critical hits Oh let's start the bullets
let's dodge the bullet there this is my
kill don't even try you will never be
floor gang I got 5 kills I'll take it
you get a brofist dick huh which you can
put on all vehicles in the game oh yeah
yeah welcome to the rights field mother
where are you going huh oh I think I
have an idea
we'll triangulate them they'll never
expect it alright come on give me back
oh yeah yeah do
feral hogs Stan this is captain
PewDiePie I'm absolutely furious that
was my kill seasick
that's not floor gang dude I'm killing
it yeah that's floor gang come on
don't even try you can't win you can
also get the j8 a premium biplane with
an exclusive PD PI's skin and the sticks
vine em kicked in it we'll use that
later we'll use tank later I just really
like playing with that with the flights
is so so fun oh it's definitely sweet
and turf now oh we're gonna brawl we're
gonna buy mom actually used to work for
the Swedish not Air Force but the one
that produced the that y'all scrape then
you didn't get anything you probably
heard about them they're famous warships
she actually flew one of the not a Yas a
gaping but another one it's a pretty
badass I'm jealous
alright time to defend Brighton new
Romney that's funny
that's nearby where I am right now this
was weird out of all places on the earth
I'm not gonna say where I am
look he's gone for him little does he
know was a man flew against Memphis
track from above look at this mess oh
there's one two three four five six
versus one how about we match those ants
Oh
you can't escape you can't escape no you
can't well Jesus where'd that come from
real and I'm not dead I'm just like my
plane is busted
Rick floor gang and they're coming in
hot I don't think so yeah that was good
sweet dude two kilometer away oh you're
so then
you're not going away you're not yeah
yeah you're playing tambourine Maya damn
you're good at that
good job maybe you aren't flooring gang
huh I'm sweating like a demon from the
Sweden or you want some huh I don't
think so
I'm only on fire it means nothing it
means nothing
visitors up Team Rocket's leaking again
[Applause]
we high on ceiling gang at floor game
floor gang logo sorry I keep mixing that
it's normal I'm not stealing game I am
coming from above though that was sweet
dude where is it going how are you going
the floor is mine you don't do that all
right it's time to tank it up that's
right war Thunder has tanks that's cool
that's it is to flying we have this
goddamn bad boy to play around with
lets-a-go okay okay yeah yeah they're
capturing see huh I see
oh you're not so tough now are ya okay
fine yoyoyo office strips manganese
darling don't you download the game more
Thunder it's fun damn this is cool
alright let's go let's go dude look we
go through the snow in Stoke that's so
cool hey let me go in your tracks bro
what I like about war Thunder tanks is
that you can drift baby dan den dan den
dan in it alright now come on this is
not thanks bro thanks bro that guy's
floor gang right there don't shoot don't
shoot
Swedish here what is he doing idiot
another one another one watch this voice
download war thunder use the link in the
description oh yeah oh no oh no oh this
bad blue onyx straight-flying this is
exclusive PewDiePie skin 1 there's a
flippin guy behind me dude
oh god this is awkward
don't shoot don't shoot don't shoot oh
he doesn't see me
for all don't you trick hello hello
maybe I'm not so bad a tank after all
huh I am speed yeah oh god um but you
weren't expecting that what hey you're
gonna give away my location bro oh yeah
I'm not afraid I'm not afraid I'm not
afraid I'm not doing any damage
alright this oh my god oh my god they
killed Fenton he bind this is bad bro
bro let me get that for you let me get
that for you bro send in their territory
wait air battle oh I hit someone what
okay what is this I didn't know you can
switch that's so cool yeah y'all need a
vote oh wow let's get that up that's so
cool oh man I messed that up
alright more artillery apparently I hit
someone we're going in boys
yeah
Oh fugu oh hello
come on that was mine
another one come on what happened here
what are you doing oh we can grab an ax
that's so cool
oh these are so fast yeah go
[Music]
oh god I forgot about trees that's fine
honestly I can still fly fine
alright gamers thank you guys for
watching this video guys check out war
thunder it's super fun no buts no ifs
honestly at a great time it's a really
fun game check it out yourself it's free
also make sure you smile link in
description because then you get the
brofist decal nice that je8 a premium
biplane with the exclusive pewdiepie
skin and that's 609
with a scholarship 85 skin download it
do it now
thanks you for watching